[Music]
the reselling aspect of sneaker culture
has changed everything I think now is
the biggest harvest nism maybe I said
I've been there's people taking money
and rather investing in a traditional
asset class to stock up on they're
buying sneakers and they're investing in
that sneaker and they're selling it on
an exchange later there is a lot of
money to be made in this game you've
gotta make 50 grand in a week and then
like I've seen people do it we estimate
that there's over two billion dollars in
gross market value of overall footwear
being resold we think stock X is the
leader in this market with pros market
value north of a billion dollars we
connect buyers and sellers the same way
that the world stock markets connect
buyers and sellers just like Apple
doesn't trade at the same price every
single day in the market nor does a
particular sneaker trade for the same
price from day to day
some people's closets you look at it and
it's a stock portfolio there's some
shoes I love so much I got 41 pairs of
the same exact shoes resale is all about
product allocation it's all about who
can get it and where you sending it that
the person is willing to pay you more we
think this party can grow from civilian
experience in a relatively short time
period these days sneakers are more like
stocks and your average trainers prices
up and down like Wall Street
some experts buy his sneaker resale
market at over two billion dollars and
it could be six billion by 2025
[Music]
we're gonna take a deep look at the
industry show you who and what is making
it move I lost a job and something that
I enjoyed doing and I was just trying to
find another job and I figured sellin
sneakers would hold me over till I found
that other job without other job never
came and we wind up opening this bank
account
got a little 2500 lot of credit line and
the day I signed the lease to my store I
have $40 to my name
so in four years it jumps from $40 to 20
million in sales to 2019 we wind up
teaming up with American Eagle and I
sell a part of my business to American
Eagle my god
urban necessities inside of American
Eagle there's ultimately some companies
here that are earning very good economic
returns on facilitating these exchanges
and I think you're seeing investors look
at these businesses very seriously
[Music]
accomplished con 6:00 a.m. right now
it's literally nobody here yet I will be
the first person to purchase the Safari
pack that is coming out three new
different shoes should be very
profitable they cost around I think 230
retail should be able to sell for about
six hundred bucks let's see how many we
could get we're also gonna be heading to
China Town market converses are gonna be
a hundred bucks should be able to sell
those for about 400 to 500 but yeah I
can't really disclose how I'm here so
early but shout out to the flood thank
you the amount of money to be made is is
essentially unlimited in their sneaker
resellers that we've seen they're
earning several hundred thousand dollars
a year it's the way to make the most
money is if you can acquire these shoes
at retail we find out where is it gonna
release who has the shoe what retailers
how limited is the shoe and if we
possibly get it before anybody else we
are the ones that create the market
there's this thing called backdoor now
backdoors pretty much getting a shoe
early from a retailer somewhere like
that or someone that works inside the
chances of any average person being able
to buy a pair of the shoes that are
highly coveted is effectively zero I
have no idea how kids get like on the
reseller spike know like what our yard
or lace crazy
never take me drowning
buyers reach out to us it's because they
know the shoe is gonna go up in value
and you know what the hype is about
especially now with all the marketing
that's going on with social media and
stuff like that we're tracking the
markets let's say the stock X is the
goats eBay and we're trying to compete
with their prices we try to buy every
pair that comes out of the store
thank you
chinatown market number one gonna be
getting chucked hey yeah yeah oh yes all
right now we're getting chinatown market
UV chucks so they actually changed
colors pretty dope shoe $100 retail
what's going on there take a size 10 hi
so I just got a size 10 high and the
converse is very very dope shoe as you
could see retailers $100 on the shoe
should be reselling for about five
hundred six hundred dollars if you have
a lot of capital you're able to hold on
to them and then eventually their end up
going up stuff like that so
this is the shoe right here we want to
flash the UV light change colors yeah
I'm Dillon or even I'm 13 years old and
I started reselling when I was 8 years
old
how much Susan money do you think you've
made since you started recently because
yes probably in the five digits I mostly
sell on stock X goat and the sneaker
phone app we have a marketplace of
buyers that come to our sites and look
for the most sought-after sneakers those
buyers have the opportunity to either
buy it at its market clearing price or
to be able to set a price at which they
are willing to buy that item on the
other side of the marketplace we have a
really dynamic marketplace of sellers
consumers individuals businesses brands
that are essentially selling that same
product and also choosing a price at
which they want to sell at I think it's
great because it's become like the Kelly
Blue Book of sneakers and now everybody
has a fair guideline that everybody has
to try to abide by because although you
might be able to get someone to justify
your added expense or a different price
like this police's what is essentially
like the wild wild west if you think the
sneaker business is worth 1 billion just
imagine what the counterfeit sneaker
business is worth that counterfeit
business is insane right now literally
you see every single shoe being
counterfeited and they sell people on
the streets are wearing them and you
can't really tell we literally only buy
from stores the only thing that can
really sell in our platform is somebody
that has bought and held a shoe that's
in perfect condition that we then
authenticate to the buyer seller sends
it to us we authenticate it make sure
not only that it's real but it's the
right size the right condition it is
what it's supposed to be and we send it
to the buyer stock bucks
I love y'all for real love y'all like
they changed the whole way I operate we
end up finding a way to get multiples of
these shoes it's literally crazy the way
we get it but we get a lot of numbers
[Music]
some of the purchases that we made a lot
of converse these are pretty much the
two sneakers of the event that are
actually profitable finding gold
especially for being by myself like none
of my team is out there so I literally
did all this by myself eight hundred and
seventy dollars of converses it's pretty
good right there I'm in the hotel yep
I'm at the hotel I'm going back right
now there's gonna be a stash right I I'm
coming I'm coming
No
[Music]
didn't sneak account I've been able to
I've come to every single show for the
last four years and in the last two
three years I've probably spent 1011
mill buying shoes now keep in mind I
started with $40 we just wanted to come
together and start but create a place
where resellers could come together with
buyers and just buy sell and trade this
is the only industry in the entire world
with anything that has to do with buying
selling trading a good that accepts all
walks of life certain retail you walk
into the store the second you walked
into the store don't matter what don't
matter how you dress it don't matter how
educated you are the second that
stereotype hits and you ask for
something and that story not gonna help
you bro they not that happens to me all
day long it's a reason why I dress this
way and more women need more son
it's a young male dominated marketplace
at this point just not to say women
won't and girls won't become more active
in this marketplace Nike Adidas Jordan
they're making great shoes for girls too
and women and I think there's women and
our major focus inside Nike in
particular that's where the influence
would need to go because those are the
people that are gonna get more more
support than the athlete the days that
our athlete being the influences those
are like that's becoming extinct the way
a shoe like build type or goes from like
a $200 to a $1000 shoe or anything like
that I would say first is gonna be
social media the rollout plans that
brands are doing now and the competition
between the major brands to make sure
that they're endorsers are doing
something different to launch a product
is just adding hype to this stuff once
everyday human sees these people wear
these shoes they want the shoe and
that's when the reso comes in because
you can't purchase these shoes and
that's where recommend because we're
gonna be the people that have the shoes
right now the reason that a lot of kids
especially the really really young kids
are able to do this is because
everything went digital
[Music]
so the statue literally have to like run
to location and scan everything with
your phone and that gives you the chance
to purchase the shoe resellers are
making the most money out of this for
sure right now the manufacturers they're
ultimately earning like I said Kyle halo
benefits the hype and the buzz is
getting created and resale is 100%
filtering back into the primary markets
it's gonna be interesting to see how the
the company started with China
monetizing you see now they putting out
more okay
flooding the market with it the real
business is ultimately working with
brands to become an alter-ego channel to
literally IPO products into existence
where brands can release products had a
true market value as opposed to this
very antiquated concept today of retail
price these limited-edition scarce Nike
Jordan easy Adidas sneakers are a form
of creative self-expression for a
demographic these Gen see millennial
consumers that are really obsessed with
being unique and differentiated there's
no shortage of fans people who don't
want the stuff now everyone is always
waiting for the sneaker bubble to burst
and I don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon my love for sneakers will
never go away
I think I'll forever be tied to sneak
economy there is a lot of money to be
made in this game there's thousands if
not millions of transactions happening
online per day it's nowhere near a
bubble I think that as stock X or
Stadium Goods get these evaluations all
it does is make people who want to
invest money in soaring markets more
aware we think this is kind of for lack
of a less cliche way of saying it a
truly revolutionary form of Commerce
like this doesn't exist outside the
actual stock market and we think that
this is not only who would exist in ten
years but this is logically how these
certain products should be sold our
parents may not have been paying
attention to this Jordan is coming out
where this airmax is coming out but when
they read something in the Financial
Times or something else that there's a
billion dollar industry on the secondary
market of sneakers that's something that
they're paying attention to and it's
open
the eyeballs it's opened up sneaker
culture to the masses
[Music]